الصوره تتحدث
محمد المشاهد الان هذه اللقطات امامكم
مباشره عند باب هذه السفينه ضخمه التي
اقلت هؤلاء الرعايه يتم استقبالهم من قبل
ممثلي وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه وعدد كبير
من القطاع او القيادات الامنيه السعوديه
التابع للقوات البحريه وزاره الدفاع
لاستقبال هؤلاء السيدات وهؤلاء العائلات
والرجال بعد وصولهم الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بعد رحله استمرت لقرابه من ثمانيه
الى عشره ساعات مشاهده على العمليات
الاستقبال بعد ان قمنا بكم بجوله خاصه
داخل هذه السفينه سفينه تماما لانه قلت
لكم خارجا لعمليات الانزال كما يظهر الان
امامكم يتم انزال العائلات والسيدات بدايه
نشاهد الابتسامه وهي بمقدمه وجيه هؤلاء
نتعرف عليك اهلين اسمي الدكتوره لينا
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله على السلامه شكرا ممكن اسالك
ايش المشاهد اللي شفتيها في السودان كل
شيء اي شيء ضرب رصاص دبابات اي شيء الحمد
لله لما وصلت القاعده ايش اللي شعرت فيه
خوف خوفنا طبعا بس الحمد لله يعني تسهلت
لما وصلتم الحمد لله طبعا كان طمانينه
يعني جينا من وضع سيء جدا بس الحمد لله
كنت مقيمه في السودان ولا تعملي في
السودان كنت شغاله في السودان فالحمد لله
ايش الدعوات السفينه اي دعوه في الحياه
طبعا
شكرا معلش بس شكرا شكرا كما ذكرنا ايضا
قطاعات الامنيه تقوم بمساعده العائلات من
خلال مساعدتهم في حمل حقائبهم لكبار السن
والسيدات تحديدا ايضا نشاهد عمليات
الاجلاء او النزول من هذه السفينه ضخمه
التي بدات العمليات من خلال ربع ساعه
الماضيه ومتوقع خلال الساعه او النصف
القادمه ان تنتهي عمليات
تنتهي عمليات النزول ومن ثم بعد ذلك انهاء
اجراءات سفرهم ومن ثم ركوب الحافلات التي
تم تخصيصها من قبل الحكومه السعوديه الى
اربعه فنادق تم تخصيصها من قبل جهات
المختصه لتسكين هؤلاء الرعايه بمختلف
جنسيتهم ودولهم واعمارهم وتوفير كافه
الاحتياجات الخاصه بهؤلاء الرعايه نتحدث
عن كبار السن وذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه يتم
تسكينهم في غرف مخصصه
لحالتهم الصحيه ومتابعه على مدار الساعه
من قبل ممثلين وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
والقطاعات العامه الرقم الاهم سلطان هو
1687 راكب عدد كبير جدا هل نتوقع المزيد
من سفن المماثله ما تبقى من رعايه الذين
يحاولون الهرب من ما يجري من اشتباكات في
السودان
بالفعل المتوقع خلال الساعات القادمه انتم
تكون هنالك عمليات اجلاء مستمره خلال
الساعات القادمه او يوم غدا كما ذكر
السفير السعودي في الخرطوم يتم استقبال
كافه الطلبات ودراستها والموافقه بما
يتناسب حتى يتم اجلائهم عبر سفن بحريه
ونشاهد
اهلا وسهلا حياك الله ويلكم دودي
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات